Stars, galaxy, in astral seas above, on cosmic paths we'll trace, man over wings.
Liberty is such a wandering thing, behind us all, come see, come take your place, we're leaving soon for-
End it, already.
Protection shield is invulnerable, ultimate weapon and we-
Calling all delegates, meeting at once in the General Assembly.
I repeat, an immediate session of the council, number one priority.
See and go on my observation screen.
A large object.
It could be an enormous spaceship.
One thing is certain, there are dozens of fighter craft accompanying it.
Yeah, I wonder.
Well, Lieutenant, how are you doing?
Are you feeling better?
Yes, thanks, Pierrot.
Only I still feel very weak.
You should get some sleep.
I'll give you a little sedative.
No, Pierrot, I don't think so.
I'm worried.
The feeling there's something terribly wrong.
Hey, you two, don't you think it's time we called?
We're okay and we should tell him.
Yes, I'll call Omega.
It's a crazy situation.
It is worrying. Who are these guys, anyway?
These humanoids who are after us. I'll call base.
Omega Control, go ahead.
This is Lieutenant Pierrot. Put on Colonel Pierre. It's urgent.
Negative. The colonel is in conference.
Well, then give me the commander.
Negative. Commander is in conference.
There's something wrong. An emergency session.
Give me Madam President. It's personal.
Negative, Lieutenant. The president is chairing the meeting. Impossible to disturb her.
Listen, it's top priority.
Lieutenant, I can't.
Okay, I want you to inform all three that I am calling.
Go ahead, I'll wait.
I can feel it. Something is really wrong.
Time is passing, gentlemen. We haven't much left.
What do you propose? Has anyone a suggestion?
What does the intergalactic police say?
The commander has just been to the calculation center. Here is his report.
The distance and trajectory are such that none of our ships
is in a position to intercept their craft and destroy it.
May I make that clear? We have no way to destroy it.
We do have allies who are quite close to the Earth.
Even the ones on Sirius and Barnard would have to come out of hyperspace, well before the solar system.
They would be too late to stop it.
Here is the estimated time for their operation as our computer service has worked it out.
Their device is at present at this location, just passing the region of Uranus.
Its path will take it past Saturn's orbit at 1340, then Jupiter's at 1425, the asteroid belt at 1440, Mars at 1455, hitting the Earth at precisely 15 hours.
According to our calculations, their base, or whatever, their control center is certainly in this region, no doubt patrolling this sector.
However, even if we were able to locate that control center and destroy it, which is in fact not likely, it would in no way help us to solve the problem in hand.
The prospect of complete destruction now menaces the Earth.
Tried sending a suicide mission of a great number of ships out of the Centaurus system that would take the risk of penetrating the solar system at hyperspace speed?
Coming out of hyperspace as close to the enemy craft as possible, would it work?
Hmm. Well, let's see.
Very little chance, none really.
More than nine-tenths of our craft would be destroyed before coming out of HS.
And even if a few did make it, the slightest error in calculation
would render any chance of catching it highly improbable.
If hyperspeed exit isn't perfect, it's useless.
It's useless anyway. It's going too fast.
In view of the fact that any other possibilities are excluded,
surely it's worth trying our only alternative.
No, no, I assure you the idea just wouldn't work.
We must not delude ourselves.
Note that the operation is well planned,
and according to photographs, their bomb is invulnerable.
Now, there's one slim chance, but it's very slim indeed.
Yes.
Go on board the thing and disarm it.
Well, that's insane.
Can you make such statements?
He lives in a dream.
How can he make jokes at such a time?
Can't you be serious?
All right, I'll be right there.
That's it.
If we have any one of our craft in the region of Earth,
We can then get aboard, and very quickly, we can disarm the rocket ship.
I don't know exactly how.
Our photographs from Titania aren't too clear, but we will have other photographs very soon.
Of course, we would need someone in the vicinity, and we have none, right, Colonel?
As it happens, in that region, there is a ship, a Hummingbird.
In that case, you get in contact.
What advice be, Colonel?
Captain, contact that Hummingbird. Top priority.
Yes, sir. At once, Colonel.
Hummingbird calling Hummingbird.
This is Omega Control calling Hummingbird.
This is Omega Control. Come in, Lieutenant.
Keep trying, Captain. It's urgent. Don't give up.
As soon as you get through to Lieutenant Pierrot, I want to talk to him.
What's wrong? I've lost contact completely.
Close to this little orange balloon.
Even if they tried calling, we wouldn't hear them.
Yeah, don't forget the interference.
We decided to stay a good distance from Saturn and its satellites for a good reason.
I know. You want to take a look at what I see here?
Fifteen minutes on a course to the right, we'll be out of the zone of vulnerability.
We'll program a little hyperspace.
And quick as a wink, we're on our way home, no problem.
Omega Control. Come in, Lieutenant. Come in.
Well, you see, there are limitations on possible ways of boarding the enemy ship.
I'll give you more details on that later.
When we've had a chance to look at the video pictures transmitted from Rhea,
analyze them, they may allow me to suggest a suitable approach, a vector angle.
Maestro, no, wait. Their craft is calculated to approach Saturn in about an hour.
And 25 minutes before the ultimatum expires.
And what would you suggest we do?
Shouldn't we warn Earth they're in danger?
Yes.
But before throwing them into panic,
we ought to be able to hold out some hope to our earthly friends.
We can't simply send them their death warrant.
And the Lunar Defense Base?
Couldn't it use its considerable power to create a wall of fire?
As I understand that the Lunar Base has sophisticated weapons.
The moon, well, it's less than two seconds from the target.
Once within its action perimeter, it will execute its mission, namely exploding.
But even if it happens in that vicinity, it will create considerable devastation.
Considerable.
No, no, no.
Let us consider other alternatives.
In any case, my friends, the craft's protection shield will allow it to resist any frontal attack.
Let's accept that.
So I can say that we are all agreed.
No one here wishes to surrender.
Oh, no question of that.
Absolutely no surrender.
We will never give in to aggression.
It's against our principles.
And so far my galaxy is concerned, there can be no doubt.
We intend to defend all our rights regardless of who threatens us.
Civilized beings must live in dignity, and for that we will fight.
Yes, I agree.
General Grouchley is a dangerous mad genius.
His terror would know no limits were he to be victorious now.
The General thinks anyone not with him is aggressively against him.
History is full of power mad dictators.
It's just as crazy as Grouchley, perhaps even crazier.
Calicula, Nero, Hitler, he was a bad one.
Their madness only helped them in their ambition for conquest.
Psychologically speaking, the origins of this average...
Well, it's not the moment.
Well, to go on, gentlemen, do go on.
It is imperative to find out whether Cassiopeia has more than this one bomb.
I believe it's unlikely, so we need only to use this one.
Hummingbird, hummingbird, this is Omega Control.
Come in, Lieutenant.
Omega Control calling hummingbird.
Come in at once, over.
Okay, kids, this is it. Going into hyperspace.
Wait a second. Hold it, Peter.
hummingbird calling hummingbird this is omega control this is hummingbird lieutenant piero go
ahead at last what's your position urgent request i'm putting you through to the colonel yes colonel
i understand what you said i know what the mission is but colonel i'll carry out your orders but i
think there's something that you should absolutely knows lieutenant listen to me there's no time to
lose now you will immediately carry out your orders program your craft as instructed now but
Colonel, you will execute your orders, Lieutenant.
In less than 30 minutes, he will be in the region of Saturn heading toward the sun.
He will be 20 minutes ahead of the rocket ship.
Let's hope he makes it in time.
Following your orders, I have programmed our trajectory as instructed.
But as I tried to tell you, we will very likely be detected by enemy fighter craft based on Mimas near Saturn.
And we may even encounter a much larger prize.
Any further instructions, Colonel?
Change course immediately toward Jupiter.
We will calculate a new trajectory for you.
Stand by.
Work out all possible paths of intersection on the Saturn-Jupiter axis.
This is the fastest one, and we need all the time we can get.
This one is safer.
Hummingbird, do you read me?
Yes, Colonel.
Okay, these are your instructions.
You will maneuver in order to circle Jupiter on the right.
Taking maximum advantage of all the cover the planet can provide,
you will intercept rocket ship as soon as it clears the planet.
You maintain the same axis.
This procedure will cost us time, but the safety of all of you is worth the price.
Carry out your maneuver, Lieutenant.
Must succeed. You're our only hope.
Radio contact in 15 minutes. Out.
I swear they will make contact at 14 hours 30.
The distance they have to travel now is only slightly shorter than that of the rocket.
Got to trust our kids. Now we have no choice.
I'd better give a little thought now to how these young people are going to get inside that darn thing once aboard it.
No need to... I don't know.
What we need is high-resolution pictures. These are so fuzzy that they're... I can't see a thing on them.
They're fuzzy as my beard.
Maneuver carried out successfully. Colonel, Saturn's orbital axis is behind us. All is ready.
Well done, son. You're still a little ahead of the rocket, but your trajectory is a bit longer.
For the record, Lieutenant, I'd like to say I'm sorry I didn't listen to you earlier.
We'd have gained precious time.
Piero! Piero!
In less than half an hour, we'll have analyzed the new pictures that we'll be getting from our Saturn relay station on Rhea.
At that time, I'll give you precise approach angle. Courage.
According to plan, General. Have you any news?
Discussion. I know him.
Believe me, democracies are great time wasters.
At the last minute, they'll hand us their surrender on a silver platter.
Good demonstration of their protection shield in action under a sustained attack.
You see what happens.
Any object attempting to penetrate the field is pulverized or pushed aside.
It's deflected, regardless of mass or velocity.
At the propulsion end, anything approaching would instantly be vaporized.
There is no means known to propel an object faster than the speed of light.
such an object would penetrate the shield.
Therefore, our solution is to approach in this narrow corridor.
Only a very small yet powerful craft could achieve this.
Unfortunately, the hummingbird is perfect.
Then what?
Piero must land on it and disarm it in time.
And they should make contact about 14 hours 30, if all goes well.
They'll have less than half an hour. Is that enough?
If luck is on our side, he should be able to make a quick entry here,
and it should lead to the ignition area.
I think that's true, because this door seems to be the one most used.
I think they should know that as quickly as possible.
Calling Hummingbird.
This is Colonel Pierre.
Maestro will now give you your final instructions.
Good luck.
Yes, well, now, here's what I've been able to piece together from the RIA data.
Please listen carefully.
There is only one weak point in the craft's defense, and here's what you do.
Chief, they don't want to.
Then we'll blow up the Earth.
It'll be a good lesson.
That's what they get for getting in my way.
Now beyond our control, Admiral.
Very well.
Return to base.
because all communication will be impossible later.
Jupiter's radiation and the ship's protection shield will block the signals.
Once you're on the craft, move fast, you'll have under 30 minutes.
The first 10 minutes, you will pass through the asteroid belt.
There on the rocket, you'll be protected by its protection shield.
But be careful, you will also be subjected to fire from our base on Vesta.
Again, you will be protected by the ship's field.
The same will happen 15 minutes later when you will be a target for our base on Deimos, near Mars.
Finally, a few seconds before impact with the Earth, the rocket will be violently attacked by the moon base, but then you should be well away.
To gain entrance into the rocket itself, don't use lasers.
They would very likely set off an explosion. Now, you wouldn't want that.
If for any reason you are unable to enter the craft, leave immediately, preferably before Mars.
The most critical moment will be when you are leaving the craft, because your escape corridor will be very narrow.
And the one end, you could disintegrate in the protection shield, and the other be vaporized in the heat of the exhaust.
Well, that's it. There's nothing more that I can tell you, my friends.
Oh, yes, your tangent thrust engines must be run up to maximum power to disengage you from the craft.
Well, we're all with you in spirit.
We'll try to monitor your radio signals until you're free of the craft.
Remember, the survival of our way of life is in your hands.
Engine thrust engines at maximum power.
Now, magnetic anchors operating.
Engines have been cut.
We get it from Vesta.
No good. We're wasting time.
We'll each take a look around the ship.
See if we can find some other way in, okay?
We'll meet back here at 45 precisely.
Hummingbird, do you read me?
This is Omega Control.
Control calling Hummingbird.
Hummingbird, come in.
This is Omega Control.
It's like it was one solid block.
There isn't a crack or a cranny in the whole darn thing.
And we don't have much time.
As of now, every minute counts.
Psyche.
In case it doesn't work, so long, slumber.
There's no way.
This is Omega Control.
This is Omega Control. Hummingbird, come in.
I know how we can do it.
Wish this thing had a rudder to steer it.
Wait a second. Yes, a rudder to steer it.
Yes, Psyche, I have a solution too.
And I bet our two ideas are just the same.
Quick, back into the ship.
Engage magnetic anchor.
Anchor's disengaged.
Anchor's in hold position.
Let's hope that they hold.
Anchor's operating.
Power on full.
Mars base is firing.
Here we go.
Seem to you that there's a deviation in the trajectory?
Yes, it is deviating.
It's changing course. It'll miss Earth.
Okay now, trajectory is good, now let's get out of here.
Disengage magnetic anchors.
Anchors away, Pierro!
Engine thrust at maximum power.
Yes, Dad, everything's okay.
The deadly rocket plunged into the surface of the sun and was swallowed up.
And the sun went on with his routine terrible violence.